[Applaudissements]
on
[Musique]
e
où
magnifique 110 spectacles
les côtés d'un tel missile dans un tel
endroit
une question que vous vous posez des
petits canards finissants cette question
est la suivante quelle est la relation
entre ce nocturnes de chopin et l'image
qui est projeté en ce moment sur l'écran
pendant la diffusion de ce mode image
qui représente bien sûr et là vous
l'avez bien reconnu une magnifique
sculpture de la fameuse double hélice de
la molécule vadel adele qui est le
support physique et moléculaire de notre
patrimoine génétique et eric fehr à tous
alors pour répondre à cette question et
un sourire un p'tit peu votre curiosité
légitime
je vais commencer par vous raconter une
petite histoire
mais il vrai mystère il était une fois
un grand scientifique
un américain qui était aussi japonais et
qui s'appelait sous l'eau ou l'eau
c'était un grand spécialiste de l'étude
de l'évolution des organismes vivants au
niveau génétique moléculaire
il a émis l'hypothèse dans ses travaux
que les répétitions et j'insiste bien
sur le mot répétition car les mots ont
de l'importance
les répétitions d'information génétique
dans les séquences de l'adel jouerait un
rôle très important dans l'évolution des
organismes vivants et dans ses
réflexions
il a fait un parallèle entre les
répétitions et les récurrences
d'information génétique dans la séquence
dans les séquences de l'adn et les
répétitions de tels musicaux que l'on
retrouve dans les partitions musicales
et après pas mal de cogitation une
réflexion il a développé une méthode qui
lui a permis de découvrir cacher
derrière la séquence d'un vrai gel qui
cause pour une vraie protéines qui
existeraient la souris mais aussi félin
nocturnes de chopin opus 55 numéro
inconnu de d'écouter cet extraordinaire
le découvrir une telle résonance
musicale caché derrière une information
génétique biologique
en fait pour arriver à cela ce chercheur
naviguer sans cesse entre deux univers
celui de la science qu'il connaissait
bien et celui de l'art qui l'a invité
dans son propre domaine pour essayer
d'expliquer de comprendre le
fonctionnement du vivant
alors aujourd'hui mesdames et messieurs
j'ai bien envie de vous emmener dans un
voyage qui permet justement de faire des
allers retours entre des univers
artistiques variées et le monde de la
biologie
c'est normal je suis biologiste alors
voici par exemple comment les
scientifiques observent sous un
microscope électronique qui permet de
très fort grossissement une simple
bactéries
mesdames et messieurs je vous présente
sa majesté escherichia coli
l'arel des bactéries commensales de nos
intestins
à elle seule cette bactérie e-coli comme
disent les victimes représentent plus de
80% des cent mille milliards n'ont pas
de mille sabords comme dirait le
capitaine haddock mais des cent mille
milliards des micro-organismes qui
colonise nos intestins
le fameux microbiote et bien cette image
est très intéressante pour les
scientifiques certes mais pour le grand
public ça ne fait pas très parlant ça ne
veut pas dire grand chose du coup on
peut faire appel à de la peinture pour
la représenter ceci a été fait par un
grand scientifique américain david wood
scène et on peut également faire appel à
de la sculpture c'est ce qui a été fait
par un grossiste artiste britannique
luke gérable qui utilisent la sculpture
d'un verre soufflé transparent de
représentation si la même table pour
présenter de façon plus générale
l'organisation de ces bactéries
si maintenant on descend vers des
micro-organismes encore plus petits
comme les virus
voici le virus de la grippe et le virus
du sida
deux virus bien sûr dont il faut se
protéger même s'il vaut le faire de
façon très différente si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire
je vais pas vous faire un dessin certes
ces images sont très riches
d'informations pour les scientifiques
mais pour le grand public ça reste assez
abstraite
du coup dans notre voyage ce qu'on va
faire on va faire une escale en
californie chez david woodsen on va lui
demander s'il voulait bien nous faire
une peinture pour 7 pour ces virus il
est très sympa il l'a fait et dont le
voyage retour on va faire une escale à
bristol chez luc gérard pour lui
demander double représente le cden micro
organismes avec cette technique de ski
en hiver souffle et une est aussi très
sympa et il l'a fait sadow 6 2 variation
sur le même thème pour représenter
l'organisation globale de ces virus
comment ils sont prostituées
l'agencement de leur composante de façon
artistique et on peut pointer certains
bible potentiel thérapeutique pour
lutter contre ces pathogènes qui
continuent à subir de sévir de par le
monde
si maintenant on descend un peu plus
valoir le chef du vivant on va
rencontrer leur composante organique
l'une de leur composante organique sont
les protéines et les deux autres
composants organiques divinement sont
bien sûr le sucre et la grèce mais ce
soir en cette veille de festivités
culinaires de noël
on va pas parler des choses qui fâchent
voici comment le scientifique voit une
protestation hier où la conformation
il trottine pour dire simplement la
forme sera celle d'une protéine il
s'agit de la protéine fluorescente verte
qui lui dans une méduse océanique et qui
émet une magnifique lumière verte bio
rien à voir avec avec celle de sebastian
tout à l'heure et bien cette faute il
est très utilisé dans la recherche
scientifique comme un outil pour
l'utiliser comme une lampe moins long
terme pour certaines études et bien il
n'y a rien de tel que sculpture pour
représenter un objet dans l'espace
devient d'accord du coup on est encore
en angleterre et va faire une escale à
sheffield jésus une artiste japonaise
qui utilisent de l'origami et elle est
très sympa aussi
il nous a fallu origami
lors de cette même protéine jsp plus
récentes
ça permet expliqué l'organisation
globale de 50 et les différentes parties
organisées en lice ont essayé et comment
ça fonctionne quand on voit cette
merveille on ne peut que se poser la
question comment y cellule de fabriquer
une stratégie autrement dit comment les
protéines sont constituées au niveau
moléculaire et bien pour répondre à
cette question je vous invite
je n'ai pas vous raconter une histoire
comme c'est à dire non je vous invite à
faire un exercice ensemble et qui va
faire appel à de la musique comme vous
savez tous pour faire de la musique
on a besoin de 12 notes de musique avec
ses 12 note un compositeur de génie va
nous offrir une composition comme c'est
une oeuvre très intéressante et avec les
mêmes 12 notes de musique
un autre compositeur va nous offrir
quelque chose de tout à fait différent
il ya différents éléments qui
caractérisent ou qu'ils définissent une
partition musicale
aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à deux
d'entre eux le premier élément qui
caractérise partition musicale c'est
d'abord l'ordre avec lequel les notes de
musique apparaissent les le deuxième
élément c'est la longueur de la
partition autrement dit le nombre total
de notes de musique celle d eau dure 4
minutes 05 quelques centaines de l'ocs
servira dure plus d'une heure des
milliers de l'autre mais toujours avec
le même 12 notre inventaire à la base et
bien pour faire des protéines le cl vous
faire appel exactement aux mêmes
principes de construction
qu'est ce qu'on vient de voir pour la
musique pour faire des procès à celle va
utiliser 20 unités élémentaires qu'on
appelle des acides aminés
ce sont des petites molécules chimiques
dont on connaît la formule elles ont un
an et les scientifiques leur attribue
une lettre de l'alphabet pour des
raisons de simplicité
je viens qu'elle une partition musicale
une protéine est constitué de
l'enchaînement dans un ordre bien précis
de ces acides aminés et contient un
nombre total
l'acide aminé lui aussi bien précis et
spécifiques des 25000 protéines
que vous êtes en train de cinq étudiants
ont bossé lui-même il faut fabriquer la
protéine va s'organiser dans l'espace
pour adopter une forme une structure
fonctionnelle c'est grâce à cette
architecture que la protéine peut
fonctionner c'est ce qu'on appelle la
relation structure fonctions voilà je
crois qu'il ya des gens à droite de la
salle qui veut me dire quelque chose
oui je vous écoute allez dites monsieur
mohamed mais notre l'amour parce que
tout le monde le fait ça ne me dérange
pas du tout d'accord si maintenant on
attribue une note de musique en acides
aminés
il est alors tout à fait possible de
traduire la séquence d'acides aminés ont
lu une partition musicale qu'on va faire
il ya de l'eau à droite qui sont pas
d'accord à gauche plutôt dit monsieur
bobo à vous voyez ça marche à tous les
coups
c'est bien joli votre histoire
mais vous le dites que pour faire de la
musique
il faut 12 notes de musique alors que
pour faire des produits il faut 20
acides aminés
alors comment faire pour avoir une
correspondance juste pour appliquer ce
qui vient de proposer du jour de droit
dans la salle y a comme un petit des
mois dans une histoire n'est-ce pas je
crois que les gens de gauche ils ont un
peu mieux suivis puisque je veux dire
que les villes de droite et n'y voyez
aucune connotation politique s'il vous
plaît eh bien nous les scientifiques
connaissent à des têtes en l'air comme
le professeur tournesol un peu
désordonné mais continue sa mutation
sans même bien classés les choses il est
très rigoureux pour ça du coup les
acides aminés on peut les classer dans
des sous groupes
parce que certains ont des propriétés
physico chimiques très similaires
certains sont par exemple comme les
poissons ils aiment l'eau on les appelle
hydrophile d'autres au contraire ils
sont comme des petits chats ils ont une
phobie de l'eau d'ailleurs google a
appelé les châssis aminés
il transcende bien sûr d'autres s'en
féliciter électriques qu'ils ont les
charges négatives ou une charge positive
et c'est excellent en faisant ce travail
de tri de classification ou de la beauty
facilement avoir douze groupes d'acides
aminés auquel on va attribuer une note
de musique et le tour est joué
ce qui est intéressant dans cette
histoire c'est que chacun de vous ici
présent où vous vous qui nous regardent
et au sénégal en roumanie
vous êtes libre et on est au pays de la
liberté par excellence d'attribuer la
note de musique de votre choix à tel ou
tel groupe d'acides aminés ainsi chacun
de vous est capable d'obtenir sa propre
partition musicale du tell tale trottine
et un jour ou peut être une nuit deux
américains se sont invités l'un chez
l'autre n'a rien clark biologiste et
jean diot informaticiens alors je le
sais pas ce qu'ils ont fait cette nuit
là ce jour là par contre ce que je sais
c'est que de cette rencontre et non pas
un bébé mais un algorithme qui inspirait
de ce qu'on vient de bord exactement un
instant et ses cales gorille nous permet
de traduire la séquence d'acides aminés
de n'importe quelle protéine vers son
équivalent en partitions musicales
ainsi on peut découvrir la symphonie de
l'hémoglobine le blues de l'insuline le
roc de la kératine ou que sais-je le
swing du collagène va savoir
voilà si mon histoire on peut la mettre
entre parenthèses avec celle d'ouverture
était le nocturne de chopin celle de sa
fermeture va être aussi un morceau
musical celui d'une protéine
elle s'appelle la speed run la speed run
c'est la prod qui constituent des fils
de soie
j'ai les toiles d'araignées j'aime
beaucoup les araignées des rassurez vous
je ne suis pas cédric villani
d'accord j'avais bien remarqué que je
n'ai pas d'arriver sur le côté né au
plafond j'espère et bien sachez que
cette protéine constitue cet hôtel qui
constituerait soit dans la toile
d'araignée représente la matière la plus
résistante l'appui solide et la plus
élastique et l'appui la jarre qui existe
imaginez une arène est en train de faire
un seul fil de sa toile mais qui ferait
le tour de la terre et bien c'est simple
ce qui ferait 40000 75 km le plaisir est
que 420 grammes et sa résistance et sa
solidité est dû à des répétitions de
certaines séquences d'acides aminés
qu'on va d'ailleurs retrouver dans son
équivalent alors je vous invite à fermer
les yeux si vous avez peur des araignées
à ouvrir bien vos oreilles et à vous
imaginé par une belle nuit éclairés en
train d'écouter la résonance musicale de
la protéine d'une toile qui n'a rennais
est en train de tisser sous la lumière
nocturne d'un clair de lune monéteau ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
où
4 est ce si vous le verra plus les
allées d'un de façon d'accord alors pour
reconquérir pour finir j'espère que ce
qu'on a vu ensemble aujourd'hui vous a
bien illustré la transversalité possible
entre différentes disciplines navigation
de ligne chez l'autre permet de partager
le savoir de façon j'espère pédagogique
et ludique permet aussi de de partager
des passions et d'avoir aussi un autre
regard sur son propre travail et sa
propre discipline et ceci rejoint ce
qu'a dit le grand philosophe poète et
écrivain français paul valéry à qui je
laisse le mot de la fin sous la forme
d'une citation il une fois quelqu'un qui
pouvait regarder le même objet comme lui
regarder à un peintre ou un naturaliste
parfois comme un physicien et d'autres
fois comme un poète et aucun de ces
regards ils étaient superficielles aucun
de ces regards étaient superficielles
merci infiniment
[Applaudissements]